Nikhil: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Starbucks in India and the US.
This is "Food Wars."
At a Starbucks in India,
we get our hot coffees in four sizes.
No. 1,
Nikhil: a short,
Joe: Short,
Nikhil: a tall,
Joe: tall,
Nikhil: a grande,
Joe: grande,
and the big boy,
Nihil: a venti.
Joe: venti.
I can't think of a single reason
you would order a coffee of this size.
Who is putting this much
caffeine in their body?
Me, Nikhil. Me.
Let's measure this to see if
it has as much as it should.
Joe: Whoa, wait a second.
Starbucks, I'm disappointed.
It's close. It's 18 ounces, ish.
All right, if I'm paying
this kind of money,
I want a bang for my
buck. 20 ounces to the T.
I think that's 20.
I was about to dunk on Starbucks,
but they actually gave
us the 20 they promised.
Cheers.
Ah.
Look into the eyes
of an insane caffeine addict.
My vision has just gone blurry.
India's iced coffee comes in three sizes.
Both: Tall.
Grande.
Venti.
And an even bigger one, we got the trenta.
I want to mention now
that our venti iced size
is bigger than our venti hot size.
The venti hot was 20 ounces.
This is 24 ounces.
And, of course, let's measure it.
Nikhil: Whoa, whoa, whoa!
Can't believe we have done this.
It's not even 16 ounces, Starbucks.
And this has ice in it,
which should melt and
give you more liquid.
Is that how fluid dynamics works?
Maybe not.
But my disappointment is palpable.
Yeah, I'm gonna go 22 ounces.
I don't know. It's 2 ounces. That's fine.
[laughing]
It's totally not a big deal.
That's, like, two sips.
I can't speak for anyone else,
but already my bladder is about to burst.
So maybe I don't need 24 more
ounces in my bloodstream.
If that wasn't exciting enough,
we of course have our biggest iced size,
which is the trenta. 30 fluid ounces.
The bladder buster.
This is for anyone who wants to spend
most of their day in the bathroom.
So you think, what, 28?
Again, 2 ounces off.
You know, Starbucks, 4
ounces more won't kill you.
Ah, this is actually pretty good.
Starbucks actually good? What the hell?
Anyone who watches "Food Wars" knows
we use this measuring cup for everything.
And I know I don't clean it,
and I don't think Joe's cleaning it,
and I don't think Yuelei's cleaning it.
So this thing, never
been cleaned -- yeah, mm.
And of course, if you're in the mood
for 96 fluid ounces of Starbucks coffee,
ba-bam!
Get yourself the coffee traveler,
aka what Joe drinks in an afternoon.
Here in India, we don't
have a huge coffee traveler.
We just have this little guy.
It's an India-edition
tiny pet coffee traveler.
It's got a lot of cool
India iconography on it.
There's a batsman, there is an elephant,
all sorts of cool Indian stuff.
And you can put in 355
ml of coffee in here,
which is around 11.83 ounces of coffee,
roughly a tall.
So, the perfect size.
We also have 1-liter bottles
for iced latte and cold brew.
Word on the street is
they contain 1 liter each,
or 33.8 fluid ounces.
It is so weird using the
US system of measurement.
I'm so used to our normal,
correct metric system.
But let's not start an actual
war over here. Sorry, Joe.
Yeah, um, I don't care.
Let's take a look at calories.
A hot venti latte in
India is 289 calories.
For comparison, a normal serving
of dal chawal is 200 calories.
[sighs]
In the US, the same venti café latte
is 250 calories.
So it looks like the US
has 13.5% less calories.
It's at that temperature where
it's, like, room temperature.
[Windows shutdown music]
My brain is Swiss cheese.
Everything I say is idiotic.
A hot venti mocha,
which is also what my friends call me,
is 473 calories.
And in the US, our venti
mocha is 450 calories.
So, according to my math, once again,
that's a calorie decrease of 4.9%.
What do you think of that, hot venti boy?
OK, Joe, it's not a competition.
Let's just try something a little sweeter,
like this venti caramel Frappuccino,
which looks, uh, decadent,
to say the least.
Oh, my God, that is so sweet.
602 calories.
And I can feel every single
one of them in each sip.
OK, genuinely, I have
had spoonfuls of sugar
that are more savory than this drink.
How can you make something
sweeter than sugar?
How?
That's a lot of calories, my man.
Ours is 470 calories,
which is also 24 ounces.
Now, I should note, in the US,
the calories listed on
Starbucks.com are, quote,
"based on standard recipes
and do not reflect customizations."
Get this out of my face. I hate this.
Why is this so -- and they put, like,
they load the syrup in here.
How can a human being drink one of these?
I don't understand.
And now, our most calorific overall drink
that we have here in India,
a venti strawberry and crème Frappuccino,
963 calories.
Oh, my God.
I didn't even think it was possible
to experience a sugar rush
and a coffee caffeine
high at the same time.
At 963 calories, this is nearly 50%
of your daily caloric intake.
So please drink this at your own risk.
And I am a risk-taker.
Whew.
I feel transported to another dimension
where everything is more colorful
and I can taste sound.
I don't know. I feel like
we should have an ambulance ready
if I'm going to finish this drink.
That's a lot of calories, I have to say.
I'm very impressed.
Our most highest calorific drink
is the mocha cookie crumble
Frappuccino at the venti size,
and it's only 590 calories.
Oh, God.
This looks so bad.
Oh, man. It's so powerful.
Like, it's so sweet
that everything from here
on for the rest of my life
is just going to taste like paper.
So, what about the cost?
This venti Frappuccino
will cost you 390 rupees,
which at the time of
filming this video is $5.14.
In the US, a venti caramel Frappuccino
is $5.45,
or about 413 Indian rupees.
Now, I want to point out
that this is 24 ounces
and not the India 20-ounce venti.
So if we break it down per fluid ounce,
it's about 11.5% cost per
fluid ounce decrease in the US.
Let me give you some context
about Starbucks in India.
They are catering to
the rich and the elite,
because it is very expensive over here.
In South India, where I'm from,
you can get a filter coffee
for less than 40 rupees,
which is a fraction of a
dollar, and it's delicious.
Starbucks would cost you upwards of $5,
and that's unaffordable for most of India.
Here is everything that
you can find in a menu
at an Indian Starbucks that
you won't get in the US.
Quick clarification.
Some of the items we have
here are location-specific
and specific to the season
that we're ordering them.
It's currently summer here in Mumbai,
and some of these items
are store-specific.
So maybe you won't get
them when you go order,
but let me know.
And here's everything you
can only find on the menu
at a US Starbucks you can't get in India.
Now, a bit of clarification.
We know Starbucks will
customize drink orders
and there are thousands of variations
and special secret menu items.
Thank you, Starbucks.
So just to make things
not completely insane,
these are the official
things on the Starbucks menu
at both India and the US.
Cool, and let's go.
All right, let's begin with
all the hot exclusive drinks,
starting with salted caramel latte.
Not bad.
Stardust mocha.
Boom, we have clarified, no sparkles.
Nothing about this screams stardust.
I don't know what you're
talking about, Starbucks,
but it tastes good.
Chai tea, or as we call
it here in India, chai.
Can I just say, it's a bit of a pet peeve
when you guys call chai "chai tea."
It's like calling tea "tea tea."
Let me describe a good chai to you.
All right, it should be
warm. It should be gingery.
It should feel like a hug from
your mum in your childhood,
and it should perk your morning up.
And it should be under 10
rupees, but this is expensive.
Hello! It's Crystelle, and
I'm here to talk about chai,
which is actually my favorite drink.
Every person has their
own recipe for chai,
but it's a combination
of spices and black tea
and some milk, and usually
sweetened with a bit of sugar.
But for me at home, in my recipe,
cardamom is the most important spice,
cinnamon, ginger, a pinch of cloves,
and my secret spice is
a bit of black pepper,
just to give that lovely,
warming, spicy feeling,
but it's not savory.
It's just a lovely blend of spices.
The flavor is not bad,
but I wouldn't call this,
I wouldn't call this a chai.
You know what? This is a chai tea!
Because it's not quite a chai,
it's not quite a tea.
Fair enough, Starbucks. It's a chai tea.
Next up, and the drink
I'm most excited to have,
thandai spice.
Now, thandai is consumed
primarily in North India
in the state of Uttar Pradesh,
where it's this drink that's sweet.
It contains spices, it
contains rose petals, saffron,
and sometimes, optionally,
you can add bhang,
which is marijuana, and
it's completely free,
legal, and optional to add it.
And people enjoy it during the festivals
like Holi and Maha Shivratri.
What, I'm sorry, did he say that
that drink has marijuana in it?
Or you can put weed in it?
I mean, this is California.
So if there's a drink you can put weed in,
you'd think that we would have it, right?
Not bad!
It's got little pieces
of pista and badam and other nuts.
How did you get thandai right
and mess up something as simple as a chai?
USA, we got a lot of hot exclusives.
I'm going to start all the way down here,
with something called the caffè misto.
Bland.
Moving on.
Almond honey flat white.
This flat white I like
because it has a nice honey flavor to it,
but straight-up flat whites,
I just, I don't get it.
Cinnamon dolce latte.
I like it. It's not too sweet.
A white hot chocolate.
Hot chocolate? Come on.
This is, like, really good,
but I don't know if I could
drink a whole one of those.
This is the caramel apple spice.
No, thanks.
Steamed apple juice.
What? Apple juice?
Hot apple juice. When are you gonna,
"Ooh, I want some apple
juice right about now"?
"I haven't seen you in forever!
Let's meet up for apple juice."
Cinnamon dolce crème.
Ugh!
Steamed milk.
Eh, barf!
Vanilla crème.
When you walk past that ice
cream place in the mall,
it tastes the way it
smells, like strong vanilla.
I couldn't imagine having
more than two sips of that.
Already my stomach's starting to hurt.
I'm gonna be so sick.
And now it's time for the cold exclusives.
I'm not having a caffeine crash at all.
[error ding]
The citrus cold brew.
Citrusy.
Out of everything, this one has
kind of a nice, mild flavor.
The cocoa chai almond.
Ooh, I just had such a mild one.
I took a big sip, and
this one is sweet again.
Vietnamese caramel cold brew.
It should typically have condensed milk,
but this has normal milk,
and it's quite good.
Nitro cold brew.
It's basically cold brew,
but if you press a button,
you drink it faster.
[ba-dum tish]
Dumb joke.
It tastes like any other cold brew.
I'd be interested to know
what the nitrogen process is.
What is nitro cold brew?
Well, they add nitrogen to it.
And you know what that does?
I have no idea.
Next up, chocolate truffle cold brew.
You know, that sounds like
something your child self
and your adult self would want to combine
if they had to collaborate on a drink.
Let's see if it's actually good.
Absolutely not.
Oh, my God, stardust mocha again.
Mm.
I still don't know what
the hell stardust is.
There are chunks of something.
Something otherworldly.
It's like cookies and cream. It's an Oreo.
It's an Oreo!
Thandai spice, same flavor, but now cold.
Mm,
hm!
Too much sugar for one
young man to consume.
I'm losing it!
I'm seeing the light.
Oh, no, I'm literally seeing the light.
There's a light above me.
You know, the funny thing is
thandai is meant to be consumed cold,
so this is the appropriate
temperature and way to drink it.
But it's layered with
so much whipped cream,
and it's so sweet.
Thandai requires a balance
of spices and sweetness,
and that's what this is lacking.
And the final two drinks
are salted caramel
and strawberry with cream,
but I already tasted those.
Maybe it got better with
time, you never know.
You ought to give everything a chance.
I'm never giving anything
a chance ever again.
And now for the pre-bottled drinks.
They've got three of
them in 1-liter bottles.
This is the iced shaken hibiscus lemonade.
Looks quite refreshing.
Mm.
That is very nice.
It says it serves four to five cups,
which, if you're in an Indian family,
they're going to make this
last for at least 20 people.
And it's very reminiscent of Rooh Afza,
which is a rose flavoring
that we add to water,
and it's super delicious.
I think this is a good substitute.
White mocha caramel cold brew.
Oh, my God.
I've gotten to the stage
where I can smell sugar.
I can see sugar.
I can hear sugar.
I think I am sugar at this point.
Starbucks signature chocolate.
Normally I would be
very excited about this,
but I am so soaked to the
brim with sweet stuff.
It's actually good.
It's, like, the amount of chocolate
you want to put in your cocoa,
but you know it's
probably not good for you.
I'm losing my goddamn mind. [laughs]
All right, starting down here.
Something you can only get in the US
is the mocha cookie crumble Frappuccino.
It's looking a little sad.
So, "Food Wars" tip, bring your own whip.
That's another one of Joe's tips!
Mm, I'm not getting the cookie part of it.
It just tastes like a chocolate milkshake.
I don't know if that's really
doing much for the flavor.
The caramel ribbon crunch Frappuccino.
I don't know how anyone could
drink a whole one of these.
The recommended serving for this, Joe,
should be, like, two sips.
It's like, sip No. 2,
and I'm good for a week.
Ugh.
The high-fructose corn syrup
is working overtime in that one.
The caffè vanilla Frappuccino.
You know I always keep this thang on me.
The least objectionable one, I guess.
Actually a little weak, to be honest.
Then again, after these two,
maybe it's perfectly fine.
Nitro, the official cold brew
of the "Fast and Furious"
franchise, Joseph.
Just pour this on your
engine, and off you go,
off you and Vin Diesel go.
It doesn't require ice.
Has a smoother flavor, right?
Now, if you want something
a little bit sweeter
in your cold brew,
you can get yourself a vanilla
sweet cream nitro cold brew.
Joe fucks with it.
We got a vanilla oat milk,
we got a brown sugar oat milk,
and we got a chocolate almond milk.
Here they are.
Not as strong of a flavor
as I thought it would be.
Brown sugar.
I'm definitely tasting it.
Yeah, not bad.
I have reason to believe
this was unshooken.
Think I could shake it without?
I would recommend this
one out of all three,
but insist they shake it in front of you.
You can get yourself an iced flat white
and an iced honey flat white.
Skip 'em.
Iced cinnamon dolce latte
and an iced Starbucks blond latte.
Not bad.
Can confirm a sip is good.
I don't know about a whole one of these.
Already I'm kind of like, eh.
Starbuck teas,
or, as my mum calls them,
"I can make this at home."
Starting off with Indian spice majestic.
Wow, OK.
Oh! Can I just say,
drinking this after everything else
is such a breath of fresh air.
You know, it's a simple tea,
but it's very flavorful, very spicy.
Would recommend.
Next up, matcha espresso fusion.
It's part of the trifecta
of three ingredients
that have become very popular in India.
Matcha, peri-peri, and red velvet.
I feel like the espresso counters
the sweetness that it has,
and the matcha flavor's there.
Again, just cut down on the sweetness,
and this would actually be good.
Now, the exclusive hot teas
you get here in the US.
The royal English breakfast tea latte,
London fog tea latte,
honey citrus mint tea,
a jade citrus mint brewed tea,
the mint majesty.
Mint, matcha, green, all bad.
The trinity of gross. I don't want it.
The peach tranquility.
And they spell it "tranquility,"
but it should be tranquili-T-E-A.
I feel like they missed a trick there.
OK, so those are the two hot teas.
It's now time for the cold teas,
starting with an iced green tea.
I feel like when you
start drinking green tea,
it's a sign of adulthood,
and there's no going back.
That's actually pretty good.
And now I feel old.
Hibiscus passion lemonade.
So many ingredients,
but I know I'm going to taste only sugar.
Hey, that's pretty good.
It's kind of flowery, fruity.
I really like this.
A maveha espresso fusion.
Oh, this is an iced matcha?
Oh, OK, sorry.
My bad, my bad. It's,
guys, it's the Starbucks handwriting.
Honestly, sometimes I think it's just
doctors writing prescriptions
on these coffee mugs.
By the way, let me know in the comments,
what's the weirdest way
somebody has spelled your name
in Starbucks?
Mm. I prefer this to
the weird hot sweet one.
Yeah, I like the teas way
more than the coffees.
So, I don't know what
that says about Starbucks,
but I'm a fan.
I feel the exact opposite.
I do not like tea at all.
And this is all the
stuff on a Starbucks menu
I have never gotten and
would like to never get.
But, gotta do it. It's the job.
So we will start down here.
At the Starbucks in the
US, you can get yourself
iced black tea and an
iced black tea lemonade.
Moving on, you can get peach teas.
We got an iced peach green tea
and an iced peach tea lemonade.
So, this tastes good because
it's peach and lemonade.
I don't taste any tea.
Green iced green tea lemonade.
Oh, grande, not -- the first GR is grande.
Grande iced green tea latte.
"Latte." Lemonade.
Ugh, I'm losing it. See? I don't,
I stop drinking caffeine for
a second, and I fall apart.
Oh, matcha? No!
No, not matcha!
Grande matcha lemonade.
All right, lemonade.
Lemonade is doing all the
heavy lifting on all of these.
I absolutely hate this.
Royal English breakfast.
Mm!
You know what'll help?
A little caffeine.
Mm!
Whoo! All right.
Also at Starbucks, you can get
something called Refreshers.
From what I can tell,
they are fruit juices
with fruit in it. Imagine that.
I would never normally get a Refresher,
I just wouldn't think to, but
now I get to try all of them!
Pink drink!
Ooh, yeah. Fruity.
Moving on, we have the
strawberry acai lemonade.
I like this.
Similar problem to a
lot of the Frappuccinos.
One taste, and I'm like,
I could get into it.
But a whole one of these,
I feel my gut kind of starting to, blech.
Just the mango dragon fruit, right?
Dragon drink.
Mango dragon fruit lemonade.
I think this is the best one so far.
[beep]
One second. All right. Don't put that in.
Moving on, we have the green drink zone.
Star drink. Assuming star fruit.
Kiwi star fruit.
Does lemonade kick it
up even another notch?
Hm, this one, I like the flavor the best,
but it's a little strong.
Yeah, all these are pretty good.
The last Refresher is the
strawberry acai.
They have a regular lemonade
and a blended strawberry lemonade.
I mean, come on. Lemonade?
Everything else that's had
lemonade in it, I've enjoyed.
So let's just go straight to the source.
Whoa, dude.
Starbucks lemonade is, like, really good.
Is this even in the top
10 things you would get
at Starbucks, a lemonade? What?
Now, if you like your lemonade,
a little bit of strawberry.
This is fantastic.
Wow.
Even after all these, this is a standout.
This is really good.
Why is this so good?
Fantastic.
Food!
We have a lot of Indian exclusives.
I'm going to start with the salads.
This is a vegetarian grain salad.
It's got quinoa, it's
got some paneer in it,
it's got corn kernels that look unborn.
I'm sure this is super healthy,
but it's also very dry.
Now the meat version of
it. It's got chicken.
I'm not really a fan of cold salads.
If you are a health freak,
you might enjoy this.
But if you're a fan of
food, you probably won't.
OK, next up, I'm going to
try all of their rolls.
Rolls are a huge staple here in India.
They're one of the most
famous street foods,
and it's great for the
working-class citizen.
This is the murgh kathi roll.
Murgh means chicken in Hindi.
Oh, that's pretty good.
Finally! Some spice!
Oh, my God. This is a life-saver.
I feel like I'm being brought back to life
after all those drinks.
This is really good.
You'll find this only in
India, but honestly, Starbucks,
you should consider selling this all over,
because it is tasty.
Next up is a kakori kebab roll.
Kakori kebab is basically
minced meat, typically lamb,
and it's served with a paratha or a roti.
I've never seen it in a roll,
and I've never seen it in a pink roll.
Mm, you can see.
The main thing about a kakori kebab is
it should melt in your mouth.
This has too much of a bite to it.
Not a fan.
Next up, chatpata paneer roll.
Chatpata means full of masala
and flavor, and it's zingy.
And paneer is cottage cheese.
We love our cottage cheese here in India,
and we call it paneer. And you should too.
Next up, cheese chili toast.
So, obviously, if you
order this at Starbucks,
I assume they actually toast
this and the cheese melts
and it's super delicious.
I can tell you right now,
this flavor profile will go
really well with Indians.
We love our cheese chili toast.
Monsoon season, mum goes to the kitchen,
toasts the bread, lot of
butter, some cheese, some chili.
Bite into it, your mouth's on fire,
but it's rainy and cold, so you're all OK.
This is not quite there,
but I feel like it could be.
Next up, tandoori paneer sandwich.
I'm gonna have to say that
this bread is a little hard,
to say the least.
Might be a bit of an old sandwich.
Flavor is good, though.
If I had any of this food
fresh at a Starbucks,
I might have a very different opinion.
So far, the paneer items
have been way better
than the meat items.
I'm starting to guess there's somebody
in the Starbucks R&D team
who really likes paneer.
Sandwiches and protein boxes, here we go.
You can get a bunch of
exclusive sandwiches,
US Starbucks, starting right here,
with the crispy grilled
cheese on sourdough, again.
Ham and cheese on a baguette.
Then we get the turkey pesto
with provolone on ciabatta.
Chicken and bacon on brioche.
Why is it -- could we get that chicken
on the whole thing here, guys?
A focaccia tomato mozzarella.
At a Starbucks, you can get
a chicken caprese on ciabatta sandwich.
On to the protein boxes.
The chickpea bites and avocado.
You can tell what's in there.
Obviously avocado, chickpea bites.
Egg and cheddar.
Cheese and fruit.
Peanut butter and jam.
Grilled chicken and hummus.
There's your hummus,
there's your pita, there's
your grilled chicken.
You can also get,
which was not available
at the store today,
egg and Gouda protein box,
a cheese trio protein box,
and a cheddar and salami protein box.
Next up, egg white and
chicken multigrain croissant.
Should I just call it a
croy-sant to upset people,
the denizens of the internet?
If you are somebody trying
to be protein-conscious,
put on the pounds, this
might be good for you.
Next up, a masala chicken croissant.
I guess you can't go
wrong with masala chicken.
You can go wrong with a croissant.
This tastes really good.
Next up, a basil, tomato,
mozzarella sandwich.
I can imagine just eating
this on a summer day.
Really yum.
Next up, creamy spinach and corn pocket.
Pocket! That's pretty cute.
As a kid, this was the only
way I enjoyed eating spinach,
unless it was in palak paneer.
But right now, I appreciate,
and I really like it in this pocket.
Next up, chicken seekh pocket.
Seekh kebab is basically minced meat,
and it's sort of pressed onto
a skewer and then grilled.
Over here, they've done
that, and then they've
chopped them into little sausage pieces.
Mm. Minty, it has that pudina flavor,
a lot of onions that have
just been caramelized,
so it's sweet but also
spicy. I really like this.
Starting with the breakfast
sandwiches and wraps,
the bacon, Gouda, egg. There's
Gouda somewhere on here.
A sausage, egg, and cheddar.
The double-smoked bacon,
cheddar, and egg. Dude.
It's good.
Ham and Swiss croissant.
A bacon, sausage, and egg wrap.
What's up?
I didn't ...
Other sandwiches you can get are
spinach, feta, egg wrap,
the roasted ham,
the turkey bacon, cheddar,
and egg white sandwich,
and the Impossible breakfast sandwich.
But you know what they do have?
Bacon and Gruyère.
Egg white and roasted red pepper.
Kale and mushroom.
Get yourself an avocado
spread. For dipping.
Bagels!
We got 'em.
Can I assume this is an everything?
'Cause it's got everything.
Cinnamon raisin.
I can tell because of the raisins.
Hey, plain. For the New Yorker, right?
Oatmeal! Oatmeal.
We got regular, and they
come with a nut medley,
brown sugar, dried fruit.
I bet it's like a puck now.
It's been sitting for a while.
All right. [crew laughing]
You can also get a blueberry one.
It's obviously just same
stuff with blueberries.
Strawberry and overnight grains.
Next up, a double chocolate chip cookie.
I think if I put this in a
microwave for five seconds,
this is a banging, banging cookie.
A tea cake.
This is lemon-flavored.
And finally, they have a banana loaf cake,
but, guys, I am dangerously
allergic to banana.
And so I wish this cake the best of luck.
Maybe you guys can try it and
let me know in the comments
whether it's worth ordering.
On to the baked goods. In the US,
you can get an assortment of baked goods,
as you can see in front of me.
I'll just start down here. We got scones.
Oh, this is a blueberry scone.
Petite vanilla bean scone.
These can't be the same price.
Cake pops.
You got chocolate.
Which one do you think is Earth
and which one do you think is birthday?
I feel like this has got to be birthday.
Glazed doughnut, ay.
Red velvet cake.
Pumpkin loaf.
You can also get a cinnamon coffee cake.
Yeah, brownie.
Chocolate chip cookie.
Available, yet not today,
pumpkin cream cheese muffin.
It is now time for ice creams.
Did you know Starbucks makes ice creams?
I had no idea.
Java chip ice cream.
This looks really good.
Check it out, son.
Yum!
Coffee, chocolate chips, and mocha.
That is something else.
I really like this.
Next up, vanilla ice
cream and chocolate sauce.
Now, everybody in India,
their childhood has involved
Amul vanilla ice cream
and Hershey's chocolate syrup.
Let's see if this sort
of evokes that nostalgia.
Ooh, the vanilla ice cream is so good.
Next up, vanilla ice cream
with strawberry sauce.
You either got the
Hershey's chocolate sauce
or the Hershey's strawberry sauce.
Younger Kini would not
have appreciated this,
but older Kini, really enjoying it.
It's fruity, tangy, sour,
and it really complements
the yummy vanilla creamy ice cream.
Next up, we have the same java chip,
but now with more chocolate
chips and chocolate sauce.
So, this is a bit of an overload.
Too much.
Are you, can you zoom in on my hand?
It's shaking right now.
Caramel macchiato.
Mm. It's really nice.
It's not too sweet. It's kind of salty.
Next, the affogato, which
is ice cream in coffee.
I love how we're taking
hot, bitter coffee,
and sweet, creamy ice
cream, mixing them together,
and somehow they're not choosing violence.
They're choosing to be friends,
harmonious in my mouth.
Affogato again, but
this is house affogato.
So I'm going to assume, Starbucks,
that this should be better.
You're putting your name on it.
Tastes the same.
And, finally, we have the
caramel macchiato ice cream.
It's similar to the small cup
of caramel macchiato I had,
except this does not have
a drizzle of caramel sauce.
If you were ordering ice
cream from Starbucks,
I would recommend the simple java chip
and the simple caramel macchiato.
No drizzle of sauces.
It's not as sweet. It's kind of nice.
Ladies and gentlemen, we are
finished with this video.
Thanks for watching.
Be sure to like and subscribe.
I'm gonna go throw up.